les années ont passé depuis questeban
Torres a quitté le centre de
réadaptation à Laval mais ses souvenirs
sont loin d'être floues
on t'emmène dans une salle d'isolement
et puis ensuite d'être seul ils disent
d'enlever tes choses mais ton linge tes
vêtements puis tout ça Esteban dit avoir
subi des fouilles complètes à répétition
sous la responsabilité de la protection
de la jeunesse une procédure qu'il juge
humiliante et qu'il dit traîner encore
aujourd'hui comme un traumatisme ça me
choquait que je dois faire ça juste pour
pouvoir prouver que j'avais pas d'armes
puis pas de drogue puis pourtant j'étais
pas du genre à consommer beaucoup puis à
mettre dans des bagarres ou dans des
situations comme seul l'an dernier plus
de 5700 fouilles complètes ont eu lieu
dans les centres de réadaptation et les
foyers de groupe au Québec d'après des
données obtenues par Radio-Canada un
nombre faran selon la Commission des
droits de la personne et des droits de
la jeunesse il faut vraiment regarder
est-ce que toutes ces fouilles là ont
été faits selon les règles de l'art
selon les les procédures qui sont mises
en place par les établissements
lors d'une fouille complète le jeune
doit retirer tous ses vêtements y
compris ses sous-vêtements enfiler une
robe de chambre ou une serviette avant
que soit examinée des parties de son
corps comme les aisselles la plante des
pieds ou la nuque même si la nudité du
jeûne n'est jamais exposé la Commission
des Droits juges qu'il s'agit d'une
procédure intrusive qui doit rester
exceptionnelle et surtout fondé sur des
motifs raisonnables pour ces jeunes là
le centre de réadaptation ça devient
leur maison alors c'est un endroit où
normalement on devrait pouvoir avoir le
respect de sa vie privée de son
intégrité dans la région de Québec près
de 800 fouilles complètes ont eu lieu
l'an dernier sans préciser combien le
Cius dit qu'il peut arriver qu'une
fouille se limite à la chambre du jeune
sans exiger qu'il se dénudent les objets
saisis vont des vices aux armes blanches
en passant par de la drogue et des
seringues notre objectif c'est toujours
la sécurité la sécurité des jeunes à
l'intérieur de ces murs la qualité n'est
pas toujours facile certains jeunes
purgent une peine en vertu du système de
justice pénal pour adolescent d'autres
ont des comportements autodestructeurs
pour vous donner un exemple
j'ai une jeune qui s'automutile de façon
très importante vraiment m'assurer
qu'elle est pas aiguille sur elle c'est
pas un objet illégal maisons pourraient
avoir des aiguilles et puis coulent il y
en a pas de problème avec les aiguilles
mais dans son cas elle c'est un problème
les données démontrent toutefois qu'une
minorité de fouilles mène à une saisie
d'objets par exemple l'an dernier au 6
de Laval 183 saisies ont eu lieu malgré
666 fois il complète et 181 fois il
sommaires c'est-à-dire faites avec un
détecteur de métal par exemple et c'est
sans compter les objets remis
volontairement par les jeunes difficile
par contre de faire des comparaisons
entre les régions parce que la manière
de compiler les données et même de faire
une fouille peu variée le ministère
santé service sociaux revoir ses
critères et qu'il soit un iforme à
travers le Québec c'est pas parce qu'on
habite en Outaouais ou en Gaspésie que
les règles doivent être différentes
Esteban raconte qu'il n'a jamais porté
plainte à la suite d'une fouille par
manque de confiance envers le processus
il n'est pas seul depuis 2015 la
Commission des droits n'a ouvert que
trois enquêtes à sujet signe peut-être
que les jeunes ne sont pas assez
informés de leur droit ces jeunes vont
être traumatisés à vivre puis je trouve
ça dommage parce que des fois ça les
empêche d'avancer puis
comme c'est des traumatismes qui sont
pas réglés
s'ils souhaitent que le recours au fouet
soit mieux encadré Esteban espère
surtout que les jeunes soient davantage
crus lorsqu'ils jurent ne rien avoir en
leur possession ici alexandre Duval
Radio-Canada Québec